ed a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono famiglia
oggi siamo su craver crevel meno ar non
so come si pronuncia è un indio allora
anche questo raga non è la versione
ufficiale alla versione è obesa o al
quale sono mi ricordo se è bello cioè
nel senso se è carino come gioca adesso
andremo a giocarci vedrò se fare la
versione ufficiale quando uscirà me lo
avete consigliato in tantissimi mi avete
detto che un qualcosa di innovativo non
so che cosa di preciso quindi di veri
inizia la lavagna su begin alla tratto
si chiama craven tra raven manor cravan
cracker non so come cazzo si pronuncia
però vabbè il nome figo cioè sembra
veramente strano comunque mi avete detto
che un videogame diciamo tra virgolette
innovativo non so in che modo
non lo voglio sapere a perfetto piove
fantastico è permesso non è esattamente
la casa di topolino questa perché siamo
entrati qui dentro
vabbè è prevista sono più av per andare
avanti va bene raga non perché la porta
lampeggia però vabbè mi avete detto a si
può esaminare anche figo si possono
esaminare le cose che poi tra l'altro
ragadi grafica mi pare di vedere che non
sta messo neanche male anzi minchia però
vabbè andiamo avanti
c'è un qualcosa c'è un calcio è una teca
andiamo a rubare tutto token un
ornamento pesante di bronzo con incise
le lettere km greven manor che non so
che cazzo vuol dire è una marca di
crackers alla rabbia c'è un tavolo c'è
una bozza ok ho preso una caraffa sto
bevendo sto bevendo premi il tasto è per
buttare quello che sta per per lasciare
a terra ok questo tipo era che tipo mese
alla dinamica più vera e quella anche se
è stato fatto con l'unreal engine che
non c'entra un cazzo ma non impatto
soprendere qualsiasi cosa mi hanno
sempre detto che un giorno avrei avuto
il controllo del mondo e vabbè raga che
cosa devo fare qui allora c'è una luce
c'è una luce ragazze una luce seguiamo
la luce
diventato tutto buio si è spenta la luce
che cazzo chi è quello addio chi cazzo è
quello di sopra buongiorno non era mia
intenzione entrare in casa sono entrato
da se questa non è la casa di topolino
chi è questo piedistallo c'è una a ciò
la torcia perfetto
mica che atmosfera raga veramente questo
veramente epico cioè non so che cazzo di
gioco è ma veramente l'atmosfera minchia
batte quasi amnesia direi cazzo è
veramente fantastico
le porte sono chiuse ha tra l'altro per
quanto riguarda amnesia dovrebbe uscire
bellissimo quadro fantastico sapendo al
posto nel poster bmw 3 che ciò dietro
va bè direi volevo dirvi raga a
proposito di amnesia dovrebbe uscire il
duro e quando ci ha voglia di uscire
magari lo facciamo
va bene avevo promesso che l'avrei fatto
si gira cazzo buongiorno senta un
secondo io sono salito perché era buio
senta io non voglio disturbarlo
va bene si pulisca il culo il prima
possibile
c'era una porta da qualche parte ecco
questa perfetto devo andare perché
lampeggiano le cose perché lampeggiano
le cose in sto gioco
e vabbè c'è una libreria c'è della roba
dentro che non so che cosa non voglio
saperlo andiamo avanti
ok si sta a perfetto la luce e torna
grande ha ripagato le bollette
direi che siamo mica che casini è
inciampato qualcuno da qualche parte è
nova perché ci sono tagliate loro raga
se mi spunta un ragno urlo se mi spunta
no non ho veramente adesso a parte gli
scherzi no ci sono troppe ragnatele
cazzo c'è un libro
vabbè c'è una cosa devo fare cos'è
questo cos'è cosa ho appena cos'è cos'è
sta roba è una sottospecie di enigma
cosa cosa opera i premi il tasto jesi
prendiamo il tuo key crime e nemmeno mi
piace troppo pronunciarla è ho trovato
un modellino in scala del wine cellar
che è un luogo va beh sembra il modello
che ho visto nelle entrate ok che cosa
me ne frega a anno perfetto mi sentivo
come va
che classe stato ragazze c'è qualcuno
che qualcuno che si muove da qualche
parte non so chi non mi interessa
neanche tanto saperlo sinceramente
comunque va beh questa è una sottospecie
di mappa credo sia una mappa che debba
esaminare per sapere più venuto ma erano
così i libri prima non me lo ricordo non
mi pare fossero così fossero così libri
prima va beh forse mi sto confondendo
con il po non è esattamente non erano
così ma vera che io porterei questo
affare al tipo di prima magari ne sa
qualcosa a ragazzi rumori cazzo mi fanno
sempre ok se cala la luce lancio tutto
paga le bollette stronzo
devo capire
ok ok sono inciampato niente panico
oh cazzo dove sei andato aiuto raga è
brutto bastardo di merda se mi fai degli
scherzi dove sei
dove cazzo sei ragazze era qui era
fottutamente qui non può trovarmi così
raga sarà da qualche allora cia fottuti
che cazzo è successo allora si è
scassato il vetro bene
raga sta succedendo di tutto allora si è
scansato che cosa cliccato cos'è cosa
sta succedendo
posso prendere gli ho già sa che figo
posso costruirmi no che forza allora
devo prendere quella roba di prima
allora come si esce via devo prendere la
roba che mi è caduta prima non vi giuro
è veramente epico come videogame è epico
non ci sono parole
eva bello melomè solo messo come cazzo
che cosa me la faccio ora lo devo
mettere incastrerà qualche parte forse
devo prima devo prima a ecco vedi che
c'è il trucco bastardi come si fa
devo ammetterlo tipo ah ok non l'ho
messo non lo penso io lì ma va bene lo
stesso non è che tipo si sbloccano le
porte c'è magari io devo mettere si cose
mi si sbloccano le porti magari ha
sbloccato una porta lì a sinistra poi ho
posizionato quella roba lì e forse c'è
in teoria con la una nuova via credo che
mi abbia aperto una porta
ok permesso
c'era un tipo ii prima e non c'è più
che cazzo è va bene io chiudo occhio
dalla porta chiudo la porta perché fu
proprio queste e poi oh cazzo se poi è
permesso sentite c'era un tipo prima che
non mi stava simpatico cos'è sta roba
una notizia
mi frega un cazzo al notai strike river
metalworks e non faccio in tempo a
leggere ma non mi importava la sua
squadra
[Musica]
avete sentito anche voi
raga sto gioco mi manda e vi giuro mi
manda in botta cioè non capisco che cup
ok la musica inquietante da morire le
musiche cazzo ok ok bene è successo già
non lo so cosa ho visto non ho capito
che car perché non posso tornare
indietro io che registro cazzo voi
potete vabbè ho visto qualcosa che non
ho capito cosa è sì allora siamo in un
software geni una cantina ecco c'è del
vino ovunque cazzo e ho trovato non so
che cosa
cosa devo fare qui tra perché ci sono
deragliate dovunque perché ci sono le
ragnatele ok bene non è rassicurante sta
cosa a eccoti brutto basta odio perché
ci sono gli scarafaggi che cazzo succede
raga dimmi che è rovesciato del vino e
non ai squartato nessuno stronzo di melo
vabbè che
raga c'è scritto vai fuori la scritta
sul muro dice vai fuori bene e io resto
qui bastardo hai dei problemi e che cosa
hai qualcosa contro cioè sei razzista
contro i favi j non ho capito eh va beh
devo uscire ok miei bloccato la strada
che cazzo come faccio io cos'è cos'è che
è successo
attenta ai tentato di stuprargli brutto
stronzo stai tentando di uccidermi
dì la verità che cazzo ci fai con gli
occhi più cos'è e mosca cieca allora
spero tanto che tu sbatta contro muro
stronzo è cosa devo fare qui devo uscire
porca [ __ ] che caga cazzo dove andare
dove dove dove cazzo ho perso la regala
torcia mi ha [ __ ] la torcia che cazzo
raga è assurdo cosa ma le ho tirato un
aleppo dio ho trovato un'altra via raga
che il culo
ok ho trovato perfetto perfetto si sta
aprendo tutto ragazzo ho trovato un
altro ho trovato un altro caso per
sbloccare un altra via ok allora
calmiamoci un secondo bene allora
abbiamo capito che quel tipo non ha
buoni intenzioni diciamo sta tentando di
stuprarmi in qualsiasi modo
eva becco c'è qualcosa da prendere non
c'è tipo un casino di vino ma potrei a
ambria garmy finché non muoio vabbè raga
usciamo di qua che è meglio la odio st
cantina maledetta
vabbè apri bastardo chiude rimane lì
dentro stronzo di merda che perfetto ci
siamo abbiamo sta roba qui dobbiamo
mettere no ma che cazzo dobbiamo
metterla lì dentro c'è dobbiamo
sbloccare un altra via praticamente
perfetto
il romics vedrete come dove devo
metterla soprattutto non mi chiede
allora devo fare ma io in teoria potrei
metterla dove voglio tipo qua in basso a
sinistra a ma io posso sbloccare
qualsiasi c'è nel senso che potrei
metterla anche di sopra c'è posso fare
quello che cazzo voglio pratica jamie
cambia le zone che figata assurda e tipo
adesso se torno qua non c'è più la villa
roba di prima lascia un altra via che
figo
[Musica]
allora calmiamoci un attimo entriamo se
mi fai uno scherzo di nuovo brutto
stronzo tp dove cazzo vai aprista porta
aprista male dove sei
dove cazzo sei andato a finire non
voglio entrare lì dentro chi è questo e
dorian gray devo andare per forza di qua
non mi fare scherzi maledetto dove sei
vabbè qua ci sono altri fogli è un addio
ai anche la collezione di modellini
fantastico se qualcuno qui dentro non
voglio saperlo sinceramente non ci sono
delle pagine ok fantasmi perché cazzo si
è spenta la luce laica aiuto ok ok
perfetto siamo noi ci sono sono quota
faq cose addio lo stanno trascinando è
permesso
senti un settore dove cazzo non da oggi
ora ga è una cosa inquietante da morire
cos'è o mio dio è uno è soltanto avrà
modellino ma [ __ ] che cazzo di
spavento va bene bene
raga è inquietantissimo super che si
chiuso la porta perché perché si è
chiusa la porta di te cos'è
oddio non c'è più riuscita che cazzo
raga
beh sta esplodendo a praga capito tutto
cosa ci fai qui brutto stronzo
raga che cosa vuoi cosa vuoi da me
dimmelo cosa cazzo vuoi da me raga
oddio come detto mi sto prada dietro
brutto strada dove cazzo dove sei cosa
fai ti metti anche a diano
ma cos'è ragazza tentando di tokyo e
palla che fai
ho tanto vinco io brutto tenuti a che
tenti di stuprarmi maledetto bastardo
tanto vinco io ti tiro un divano alla
prossima volta
e c'è ma io mi giro così poi numero tre
davanti
ok ok ok site la stringo volentieri la
mano ma non adesso
vabbè io vado via vado via vado via vado
via vado via cos'è sto quadro devo
capire cosa devo fare per uscire di qua
non si sa cosa fa e strisce
raga ma ve lo spiegate il senso di
acciona corda lì c'è una corda c'è una
corda finché striscia va bene finché
striscia va bene dov'è andato io direi
di si può a c'era un trucco di tempo che
c'è il trucco si è aperta la porta
perfetto usciamo di qua che già non
sopporto più sto posto di merda
vabbè la porta è chiusa perfetto note
e perfetto trovato la libreria si lava
con la libreria lag allora qualcosa
questa è un'altra nota va beh devo
tornare indietro come cazzo torna
indietro che non c'è più la strada di
prima come chrome e torno indietro
spiegato e melo raga non lo so vabbè
permesso non c'è più la passi c'è di
nuovo perfetto c'è di nuovo anche dorian
gray
ci siamo di nuovo allora apriamo la
porta usciamo di qua posto di merda
altro che casa di topolino altro che
quello [ __ ] come faccio allora qua
devo mettere un'altra roba che per chi
sta qui credo si perfetto ci sta ok ci
siamo
andiamo in basso ad ragazzi veramente
inquietante da morire sto gioco io vi
giuro dove lo spot a di sopra perfetta
ma c'è anche alla luce indica lui mi
sono sbloccato la nuova zona perfetto ok
che poi tra l'altro laganà loro anche
ben capito lo scopo cosa è successo cosa
hai messo il mostro vi sta aspettando
nell'ombra si l'avventura l'avevo
intuito e posso sentirlo muoversi
attraverso i muri più avvio lui va della
mia presenza e ci credo cazzo vabbè
chiuchiù di kew di tutto chi io sono un
fanatico di più devo chiudere le pa
l'ora quel tipo il laboratorio di dexter
devo devo tirare giù un libro e si apre
la porta dalla libro giusto ma deve
essere una roba in sequenza ho capito la
prima questo ok ma si sente tipo un
pianoforte che picchia quando sbaglio
allora deve essere questo questo è
questo qui ci siamo
libreria ragazzi siamo e vabbè che
successi spegne gianluca non sono
neanche entrato cazzo già si spengono le
luci
va bene
va bene io sì checa [ __ ] ancora me ne
vado da [ __ ] me ne vado non si apre
avvio che cazzo se porca [ __ ]
ok chi ti ha detto di aprire la forma
non è maleducazione aprire le porte
cazzo senti io devo passare levati dai
[ __ ] che non passò cosa ti strisci
che cazzo ti street
[ __ ] ti becchi le sportellate in
faccia ti vecchie è tutto
ecco al patuano ti aiuta prendi xvi ha
aperto la faccia qualche problema se ti
schiaccia al muro novero brutto stronzo
allora stai le ragazze io mi giro paura
di trovarmelo è infatti è lì che
striscia
devo un altra roba coi libri ho capito
cassetti pollo e tre stella devo fare
tipo uno due tre stella ok ci sai
giocare a sto gioco ci sei giocare bravo
serio che sei più bravo di me di quando
ero piccolo va bene ok ragazzi e questo
che crea occhi e perfetto ci siamo siamo
a tre manca 1 credo che sia questa ivy
basta no che è perfetto non sta lì ce
n'è un altro che lampeggiano c'è
soltanto questa guarda brutto bastardo
che un amico guarda guarda ho vinto
brutto stronzo vinto io ok
gioca a vita o vi è brutto
mamma mia quanto ci godo ma quanto ci
godo cazzo ti sei schiacciato brutto
stronzo quanto c
mamma mia che goduria lo schiacciato
quel bastardo
raga pollice su per la sottiletta questa
me la mangio col panino
va bè ragazzi sia ma abbiamo preso il
pezzo di bronzo che dobbiamo mettere al
piano di sotto dove c'era l'incavatura
di prima guardate sono contentissimo di
aver schiacciato quel manichino dai
cazzo vi giuro ok cos'è sta roba
cos'è e l'onda energetica cos'è stato ea
mi sta indicando che devo mettere cosa
cosa che cazzo fa cioè andato cos'è il
binario 9 trequarti questo devo correre
non funziona
ok io direi di mettere so che in europa
nel muro e si apre il muro ok perfetto
ci siamo
c'è l'ultima c'è la ragazza è l'ultima
ok che cazzo cos'è paranormal oddio
cos'è si sta a fa la sua questa qua è
automatica è la 2.0 è aggiornato
versione questa fa da sola ok mettiti tu
vai hanno capito una nuova zona che figo
ha quindi ci sono altre mica altre zone
la gamma quanto e cazzo ce ne sono ok
va bene c'è un'altra c'è tutto un tunnel
mica che casino
a parte il fatto che me ne manca una qui
poi c'è addio
raga è un cast veramente un casino
assurdo io direi direi di concludere qui
larga perché c'è io pensavo di finirlo
in un episodio ma invece evidentemente
non ce la faccio
direi di continuare in quello dopo
ovviamente questo era soltanto l'inizio
e non vedo l'ora di vedere che cazzo mi
riserverà ancora sto gioco adesso che
c'è non c'è più il tizio ma ci sarà di
sicuro qualcun altro va beh io direi di
chiudere qui i semi dove è piaciuto come
al solito lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video trovate nella descrizione se non
sei dai prestiti scrivete 15 vediamo non
prossimo video bella ragazzi